but first we begin with Ryan maffey on
the scene of a deadly crash that left
six people in the hospital
yeah Brian a lot of damage here
involving a lot of cars a lot of people
this is all happening at the
intersection of Di and Jones if you can
Pan the camera off you can see all the
different cars that we've counted about
five or six cars with major damage if
you can see that brown truck that's
facing away from us they are on the
wrong side of the road the car in front
of them both have major damages to the
front ends of their car what Metro has
confirmed to us so far six people taken
to the hospital one person announced
deceased on scene they say it happened
around 2 30 this afternoon and we did a
little bit of digging into this just in
the past 12 13 hours today this is the
fourth fatal car collision that we've
seen here on our valley roads we're
waiting for more information in regards
to what specifically happened but all
you can see right now is a lot of Glass
on the floor a lot of police officers
taking photos and this had Major Impact
of the traffic in the area since the DI
area between Red Rock Street and Jones
has been closed off that's just a block
but that is impacted traffic throughout
the entire Community coming back here to
me live we are waiting for more
information from Metro on exactly what
led up to this Collision in the meantime
I'm gonna send it back to you guys in
the studio reporting live near Di and
Jones right Matthew 8 News Now